And so, our future recipes will be in accordance with FDA regulations.
Look according to our YouTube Analytics,
our viewers don't even want these grisly recipes,
they want cute, fun Halloween recipes that they can share with their friends.
Check out these things that we saw on Pinstagram.
We've got Owl Pretzels,
Strawberry Ghosts,
Pudding Pumpkins,
that's what they want to see!
Cordon?
Cordon are you listening?
Are you serious?
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!
THE WOKKING DEAD!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!
Welcome to this secret episode of
The Wokking Dead!
We're cooking another recipe, all before Dave gets back form the meeting.
RoaringCorgiProd writes,
Well Corgi, I've got just the thing.
Preheat to 350°.
Then, gather
Dave: It's pronounced, licorice.
Cordon: Ah, Dave. Just in time to lay the eggs.
Dave: You know you missed the board meeting this morning?
Cordon: Didn't you see? I was there.
Dave: Did you at least do the Culinart Productions intro?
Cordon: Nobody cares about your stupid company Dave!
Dave: Seriously Cordon?
I've had just about enough of you.
Cordon: Someone woke up on the wrong side of the three bedroom condo complete with jacuzzi today.
We're gonna need the mixer for this.
Ooh! Baby brain!
Even better three months later.
Dave: If you were at the board meeting this morning you would know that didn't meet FDA regulations.
Cordon: Oh, shut up Dave!
Alright, we're gonna need butter,
sugar,
Alright...
And now for our next thing,
We're gonna have a very special guest help us.
Everybody give a warm hearty welcome, to Chris!
Hey Chris, how you doing?
Chris: What up Cordon? How you been?
Cordon: Welcome to the show.
Chris is gonna help us beat the egg!
Take it away!
Chris: Hell yeah.
Cordon: Ooh! Whoa! WHOA!
Chris: That's how you beat some eggs. Zombie style!
Cordon: Thanks Chris...
Moving on.
Now let's add some cream,
milk,
and food coloring.
Chris: Wait! Cordon. Wait wait wait!
Cordon: Whoa!
Chris: I'm not done yet.
Cordon: Oh! OH!
Cordon: Thank you! Chris! Thank you Chris!!
Chris!
Chris: Oh, my bad Cordon.
I didn't know where I was for a minute.
It felt good though.
Cordon: Thanks for coming on the show.
Chris: Now I'm done.
Cordon: OK........
Once your mixture is good and domestically abused,
Scoop the battery,
I mean, batter,
Into the liners.
We're gonna oven these for about 20 minutes,
which means we have enough time for a quick round of,
The rules are simple.
I'm gonna feed Dave here, one of my creations.
If he can guess what it is correctly, I'll let him go.
Dave: Is there any reason my hands are tied behind my--
Cordon: SHUT UP, and eat!
Open up!
Cordon: Yes....
Dave: This is... this is spicy!
Cordon: Oh yes...
Dave: Ugh... Oh my God!
Cordon, what did you give me?
Cordon: I don't know.
Dave: Milk? Milk!!!
Cordon: I'm afraid it's not milk Dave!
It's a Cuban Ghost Pepper!
People who eat it become ghosted!
Dave: *choking and gasping for air*
Cordon: Better luck next time on...
Ahh, they're alive!
Now make sure you give them time to cool before adding the frosting.
Ok.
Yes.
Alright.
Normally I like to make my own frosting,
but I think Dave will appreciate this frosting, from Jillette.
Now for my favorite part of the process,
killing the cupcake!
AHHHHH!!!
Now the recipe calls for food coloring.
But I prefer real human blood because I need my iron supplement.
It just tastes better.
Now into surgery I go!
Now take some licorice and stitch them back together.
That's good.
Gotta be delicate.
Now while you can wait for a well timed lightning strike,
I prefer to use a taser.
Nice color.
Dave: No no no no no!
Cordon: Oh! Sorry Dave.
Dave: No Cordon... Aghhhh.
You know you could have killed me with that pepper.
And now you're tasing people?
You're out of control!
Cordon: Is this your taser?
Dave: We are going to have to have a very serious conversation about your future with this show.
Cordon: Oh! My bad.
Consider this my apology.
Dave: Oh. OK. Thank you.
Thanks for watching The Wokking Dead!
Remember to subscribe for more dangerously good treats.
You have an idea for a recipe?
Leave it in the comments.
Remember to try these things in your own kitchen.
At your own home!
See you next time!
Dave: No you won't...
Cordon: What? What's this?
Dave: You're not going to see them next time because YOU'RE FIRED!
Cordon: Fired?!
Chris: AHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!
Chris: Now I'm done!